hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
important claims made by John Stuart
Mill in his work on Liberty in Chapter
two in particular is that we shouldn't
be in the business of silencing opinions
but rather ought to allow those opinions
to be expressed even if we think that
they're false and his argument isn't
simply based on the right of everybody
to free expression as a matter of fact
earlier in the work in Chapter one he
said I'm not gonna worry about abstract
principles of right I'm gonna look at
utility at what's actually useful what's
beneficial to the community as a whole
and to the members who are parts of that
community and another thing that fits in
with that too in Mills conception is the
usefulness of allowing this for the
development of human beings for human
beings to realize the potentiality and
the kinds of beings that they are that
is rational beings and so he tells us
that we shouldn't silence opinions
whether they're true or false for a
number of different reasons he says that
the the peculiar evil of silencing the
freshen of an opinion is that it is
robbing the human race and then he makes
a couple points here posterity as well
as the existing generation those who
dissent from the opinion still more than
those who hold it so notice again he's
not saying well everybody should be able
to express themselves and you're
violating their right by not allowing
them to express themselves he's saying
it's actually bad for everybody at this
point in time and later on if you don't
allow the opinion to be expressed so
this is a much wider range past or
rather present and future although we
could also talk about you know people in
the past although a utilitarian isn't
going to view that but we could talk
about certain you know relations to them
the capacity to bring their ideas back
to light and now notice this those who
dissent from the opinion the people who
are arguing against it as well as those
who hold it
those who dissent from an opinion are in
some way harmed by the suppression or
silencing of that opinion and that's you
know in a way kind of a paradoxical
thing to say because they're the ones
who want to shut everybody up right so
why would they want to do something that
actually goes against their interests
well he goes on and he says if the
opinion is right what happens they're
deprived of the opportunity of
exchanging error for truth and you might
say well you know they're less
interested in that and they're more
interested in other things the reason
why they want people to shut up about
this thing over here is because they
have some emotional attachment to it
Milken say yeah perfectly fine but he
does think that everybody is in fact
benefited by learning what the truth is
and harmed by being deprived of it even
if they have an emotional attachment to
some sort of falsehood that they you
know perhaps grew up with or
it works to their interests or anything
along those lines it silences the the
voices in their head raising objections
the other thing he says okay so the
opinion could be right in which case
you're silencing it you're being
deprived of truth it could also be false
and you might say well then that's great
shut up the falsehoods and mill says no
that's actually not good for you why not
because in the clash of opinions the
truth of what is true becomes more clear
becomes more vivid and we are also able
to know it as true and not merely
something that we accepted on faith or
on the basis of having grown up in this
place rather than another he's got a
great example a little bit later on
where he says that the same causes which
make a person a churchman in London
would have made him a Buddhist or a
Confucian in Peking right people grow up
at a certain place and they just sort of
accept that that set of ideas Mill wants
to combat that he thinks that's a bad
thing so he says that one of the main
problems with this is what he calls an
assumption of infallibility
infallibility means the inability to
make a mistake the inability to go
astray and you know there aren't
actually that many for example religious
communities that claim complete and
fallibilities people often bring up
papal infallibility that's actually a
pretty narrow restricted doctrine if the
Pope you know says ham sandwiches are
better than that then pastrami on rye
well you know that's that's not within
the province that doesn't fall within
infallibility there is also a certain
kind of infallibility that's accorded
for example within the Muslim world to
the decisions by certain people but it's
actually you know there's often the
capacity to say no no I think this is
wrong infallibility in religious context
usually ends up being invoked as sort of
a okay we've got a controversy somebody
is going to make a decision but in it
within the wider world which includes
religious people but also secular people
lots of people behave as if they are
actually infallible or the people that
they listen to are infallible and mil
says well really nobody is infallible
there's there's no good reason to think
that anybody is if you wanted them to be
infallible that would self would have to
be based on an opinion that had to be
backed by arguments and claims and stuff
like that
so he says that you know an opinion
which is it which is attempted to
suppress by Authority may possibly be
true how do we know whether it's true or
not that's going to come up a little bit
later says those who desire to suppress
it deny its truth but they are not
infallible they have no authority to
decide the question for all mankind and
exclude every other person from the
means of judging when a person is
behaving as if they are infallible
that's in effect what they're doing
they're saying I decide everyone else
shut up
we're done here go home and believe what
it is that that I've decided is true so
he says that to refuse a hearing to an
opinion because a person is sure that
it's false is to assume that one's own
certainty is the same thing as absolute
certainty and Mill goes a little bit
further than this and says all silencing
of discussion is an assumption of
infallible 'ti whether a person has the
concept of infallibility in their mind
or not they are behaving in such a way
as to assume as to project infallibility
and Mill thinks that this is a very
problematic why well he gives several
arguments here he says unfortunately for
the good sense of mankind the fact of
their foul ability is far from carrying
the weight and they're proud
chuckle judgment which is always allowed
to it in theory everyone knows himself
to be fallible few think it necessary to
take any precautions against their own
FAL ability or admit that the
supposition that any opinion of which
they feel very certain may be an example
of the error to which they acknowledge
themselves as liable this applies to
everybody everybody according to mill
tends to have this this capacity for
going from you know saying it could be
wrong about this to thinking no I can't
be wrong about this he also points out
that people in power who are someone
insulated from dissent this is going to
be a bigger problem for for them so he
talks about absolute Prince's or others
who are accustomed to unlimited
deference we might think of you know
CEOs within companies who make terribly
stupid decisions and ruin the company
because nobody around them is actually
telling them hey that's a bad decision
your opinions are wrong
or when they do they get fired all right
he says people who are more happily
situated who sometimes do hear their
opinions dispute it and are not wholly
unused to be set right when they're
wrong place the same unbounded reliance
only on such other opinions as they're
shared by all who surround them or to
whom they habitually defer so quite a
few people will say well I I could be
wrong about this I will entertain other
possibilities but I'm only going to
listen to people that I actually like or
already agree with and so you know
that's not going to be particularly
helpful either why is this a problem
well mill says that the freedom to
contradict opinions is something that we
really need he says complete liberty of
contradicting and disproving our opinion
is the very condition which justifies us
in assuming it's truth so this can apply
to manners of action as he's talking
in that passage or this could apply to
theoretical matters as well when we
decide to behave in a way that projects
or assumes infallibility on our part or
on the part of a community to which we
belong then silencing opinions what
we're doing is removing from ourselves
the very capacity to see if we've got
things wrong it could be that an opinion
that we're suppressing is actually the
truth and we wouldn't know it because
we've silenced the people who are
expressing it or you know burn the books
that it is expressed in or shut down the
websites or however we want to frame it
now he also talks about matters of
action and in he uses some vocabulary
that probably requires a little bit of
explanation in the early modern period
all the way into say the early 20th
century people would talk about moral
certainty as opposed to say theoretical
certainty or certainty per say moral
certainty is this this idea well we
don't really know practical matters a
hundred percent but we can we can base
on probabilities we can say I've done my
due diligence I do in fact understand
what it is that I'm saying here so he he
says that you know for example there is
no such thing as absolute certainty but
there is assurance sufficient for the
purposes of human life we may and must
assume our own opinion to be true for
the guidance of our own conduct and it's
assuming no more when we forbid bad men
to pervert society by the propagation of
opinions which we regard as false and
pernicious and Mill says well this isn't
actually going to get you what it is
that you're looking for here and he
talks a little bit later about shifting
the ground here
from focusing on truth to the importance
of a doctrine to society so you know
what would be some examples of this he
does provide some some examples of his
own time but I think it's better if we
look at contemporary examples think
about all the things that are matters of
controversy where people have wanted to
say you you can't bring that into the
discussion so you know Mill would be
pretty open when it comes to this one
one prime example would be should you
actually allow self-avowed Nazis into
discourse or should you you know kick
them out or punch them in the nose or
things like that middle would say you
got to let them in so that people can
actually see how horrific they you know
the consequences of what they're
proposing would be we could also think
about we don't have to go to you know
such extreme cases we could think about
things like legalization of drugs
something that after you know several
generations here in the United States or
the war on drugs people have some very
very strong opinions about often not
particularly based in research but quite
often based in popular culture and
propaganda mill would say well you you
know Pro drug people pro-legalization
people you need to actually listen to
even if you think that it's complete
nonsense you need to listen to the stuff
that other people bring in and likewise
you anti drug Crusaders you need to to
listen to what it is that other people
bring in as well and by doing that
they'll you know it's not going to be a
sort of like well everybody's got their
own opinion kind of relativism the stuff
that's garbage will show itself as
garbage and people will be able to turn
against it it's kind of an optimistic
view of things but it is Mills
consistent point of view he also makes a
really important point when we're
shifting the ground here we are actually
shifting to the another criterion of
usefulness the usefulness of opinion to
society
all right and he says that the
usefulness of the opinion to society of
say you know we shouldn't allow people
to do X that's also a matter of opinion
so that also can be brought in for
questioning
that can't be set up as sort of an
impregnable unassailable axiom that we
all must buy into so you know that that
actually covers a lot of ground another
thing that he talks about going back a
little bit into the the chapter is this
this future of human beings and I
mentioned earlier at the start that Mill
thinks that being deprived of the truth
and the opportunity to consider the
truth is really a harm to human beings
because it impedes their development so
he does have a rather strong conception
of human nature we have certain
faculties intellectual moral aesthetic
and those elevate us above the animals
and we shouldn't reduce ourselves down
to that being deprived of the capacity
to fully develop these and how do we
fully develop these well it's in large
part by the progress that gets made in
considering opinions and then saying
well these these are actually true or we
think these are true for the time being
and these are false we're gonna reject
these so he says when we consider either
the history of opinion or the ordinary
conduct of human life to what is to be
ascribed that the one and the other are
no worse than they are isn't that an
interesting way of asking the question
why are we not more screwed up than they
currently are and he says it's not the
inherent force of the human
understanding why it's not it's not just
that we're rational beings or
intellectual beings he says on any
matter not self-evident
what are matters that are self-evident
the whole is greater than the
one of its parts two plus two equals
four right if you if you really want to
contest those you're probably just being
perverse or you're using language in
weird ways all right once we get past
that domain everything's sort of up for
grabs and he says on any matter not
self-evident there are ninety nine
persons totally incapable of judging it
for one who is capable and the capacity
of the hundredth person is only
comparative the majority of the eminent
men of every past generation held many
opinions now known to be erroneous and
did or approve numerous things which no
one will now justify it's kind of funny
because we usually when from the vantage
point of the present we're like oh you
know those those people in the you know
early 20th century in the 19th century
oh my gosh look at how stupid they were
well that's you know we could only say
that when we actually don't know much
about the history of ideas in that time
but he's saying listen previous
generation from us they had a lot of
crazy ideas about things and now those
have been disproved there has been some
progress how does that happen he says
why is it there is on the whole a
preponderance among mankind of rational
opinions and rational conduct how do we
get to this point where we're actually
pretty well off he says it's owing to a
quality of the human mind namely that
errors are courage' ball they can be
corrected human beings are capable of
rectifying their mistakes by discussion
and experience kind of a nice idea there
isn't it he points out something that's
really important he says not by
experience alone there must be
discussion to show how experience is
interpreted and then he points out
there's a great line wrong opinions and
practices gradually not right away
yield to fact an argument but facts and
arguments to produce any effect on the
mind must be brought before it very few
facts are able to tell their own stories
without comments to bring out their
meaning the whole strength and value
that of human judgment depending on the
one property that it can be set right
when it is wrong
reliance can be placed on it only when
the means of settling it right are kept
constantly at hand what does that mean
for us
unless there's free discussion this
apparatus this sort of you know cause a
fact thing about you know realizing
things are wrong it's not going to
happen in order for the human being to
actually arrive at true judgments they
have to be able to sift through multiple
points of view and those multiple points
of view must be allowed to make their
case so that is why silencing opinions
is really a bad idea Mill is producing
quite a robust argument here
you